Welcome
to the h three podcast experience.
How's that?
Pretty good periods.
We got super powers over.
This is a fucking experience.
I don't see Joe Rogan's podcast lighting
up with reverb and lightening bolts.
No,
no,
I'm good.
Thank you.
To Dollar Shave Club and Fort Night for
sponsoring this episode of the podcast.
Guys.
We started late today because my day so
far has been pretty messed up.
Oh my God,
Dude.
What happened?
So
having breakfast this morning,
you know,
getting ready for the day and um,
I see shredder on his little bed next to
the breakfast table,
a chewing on this weird little blue
thing.
And I'm like,
what the hell is that?
What does,
what does,
what does shutter gotten himself into?
And he's like,
he's the pickiest eater in the world.
He doesn't eat anything but this little
thing,
of course you eat this.
And I pick it up.
And what I ended up saying,
I thought it was like maybe a piece of
detergent or something.
But what ended up being was a fricking
adderall pill that was covered in
plastic and he was like munch like
halfway through it.
So I'm online looking up like,
what is this?
I'm like,
it's adderall.
Who,
who the hell left adderall on my floor.
So I call the vet,
the vet says call poison control,
poison control.
Well,
he's a little guy and the amount that he
ate pretty much crosses right over the
line of being toxic so to like,
you need to take him to the vet
immediately and induce vomiting and
shoved charcoal down his throat.
And I'm looking at this sweet little guy
by the way,
shredder.
Who's the light of my life besides you?
Yeah.
Whoops.
Um,
and,
and I'm like,
dude,
this guy is going to go through like the
craziest day.
They're going to go pump his stomach.
So I get in the car because he,
he seems fine.
He just basically ate a bunch of crack,
which,
what adderall is.
So I'm in the car driving on the way to
the vet.
He seems fine at halfway there he starts
shaking and crying and he's confused.
He's like panicked and it's apparent
that the drug had,
had started affecting him.
And um,
and I'm like crying because I'm so
fricking scared.
My little guy and isla is out of the
country,
out of the country with her family.
It's A.
Anyway,
we get to the vet.
He's fine.
They pumped his stomach.
He's a sweet little guy.
Point is.
Sorry I'm late.
My little guy almost went though.
I don't know if I can handle that.
Don't just break you man.
Well,
he.
I was talking to Eli about it and she's
like,
if anything happened,
shredder,
I swear to God I.
I couldn't handle that.
She's like,
I couldn't handle it.
I know what I do because she's over
there to take care of her.
Of her father who is sick right now.
Woo.
Anyway,
he's fine.
Yay.
But who walks around with an adderall
and their pocket?
Just free flying.
Just free flying in the pocket.
Any small creature that comes across in
the vet said when he puked,
they found the pill was blue and they
found all these little blue specs like a
ton of the drug and his stomach.
She said it's a good thing.
You brought them right away because he
puked it out and he.
He,
I think he would have died,
certainly if I didn't catch him eating
it right away,
he would have died crazy.
So anyway,
so that's about that.
That's why we're late.
I don't know if that was an interesting
story,
but um,
I was,
I was very upset,
but he's okay now and I'm also,
I'm the wizard of loneliness this week
because Isla has gone.
She's back helping her family and I am
truly the wizard of loneliness.
Shredder was gone with my parents the
other day and I was just sitting there,
damn,
cast loneliness on myself.
Level 90 nine.
But anyway,
I'm here to entertain and that is what I
shall do next.
Friday is the great and wonderful Bo
Burnham,
which were all super excited to meet and
chat with him and we're going to talk
about his amazing film that's coming up.
Very excited about that,
but we've got a lot to get to today.
We've got the Tan of Khan Khan.
It took me a while to wrap my head
around the icon thing.
This was like a rollercoaster of fraud.
The thing about Taneka,
and I've seen a lot of people talking
about it,
the thing that Kinda surprised me most
like I'm not a lawyer,
I have dealt with a lot of legal stuff
though,
is that I'm like damn,
like they're off being like,
yeah,
I fucked up,
but a lot of people aren't acknowledging
that it seems to be criminal fraud,
like straight up,
like the FBI might want to say what up
to her and a couple of weeks from now I
want to get into that,
but first let's break the ice because
I've got to clip.
That might be the best thing I've ever
seen.
I'm just going to pop that up there.
Get the mood set,
get the feeling right,
man.
Being in the trenches solo was a fucking
brutal dude.
But here we go.
No sound.
There's no sound on this.
So this is.
There's no sound on this,
right,
Dan?
Yeah,
no,
no.
So basically what you're seeing is
there's A.
I think they were shoplifting,
right?
They're shoplifting and they try to
escape as a police officer,
he brings her to the doubt.
He brings her down.
They're all kind of having a little orgy
there at the entrance,
kind of just tussling around,
so dude escapes from the police.
He's.
He's running into the storage,
the basically the back area where they
store all the Saudi pops.
As you can see.
Now this video is so perfectly like shot
and set up and the twists and turns in
it.
He's throwing halls at the officer.
The officer has a gun pointed at him.
What does he do?
He armed himself with a bag of halls.
Lawson.
Well,
I'm getting ahead of myself.
By the way,
these police officer pants are kind of
Gucci's.
Fuck.
They got nice taping men.
The leg.
It's pretty stylish.
How did she escape?
This is in Canada by the way,
if you need to know if this was an
America,
they'd be fucking bleeding dead on the
floor.
It Ganada.
This girl's just wandering around.
You know what I mean?
There's two officers and she's still
wandering around the store.
Anyway,
he's armed.
Oh,
little taser.
They're straight to the floor.
Did I miss the bat?
The.
Oh yeah.
Here this motherfucker arms himself
with.
What does it say?
Spritz?
They look like a bag of peanuts.
Our son.
Here you go.
If you stay one step closer,
mad,
I'm going to hit you with this bag of
peanuts.
His threats sadly did not avail as the
officer was,
was better armed than him sadly.
So he's.
He's pretty much in submission,
but nope,
he got a second wind folks.
He's got a second one and his,
his,
his wife is on the loose and he pushed
through it says back the fuck off bitch
is what he said now I.
Yeah,
that,
that was a.
That was a real spill.
I've wondered if this video is fake,
but that's spill is real.
Folks.
Let me tell Ya.
That was.
Oh,
he's got his.
He's got his knee right on his fucking
dick bone.
They're pretty.
So the girl has got a.
she's like,
Yo,
listen,
the cop just need my boyfriend in the
deck.
He's probably impotent from now on.
So she's like,
I don't have any much use for this guy,
so I'm out of here.
Peace.
She tries to sneak out and that's true
love folks.
She's like,
he's fucked.
I'm out of here.
Peace.
There's the bag of a spritz that was
thrown at the officer.
Those already.
Those are evidence.
Now,
exhibit C,
did this guy,
man,
this officer,
this is like a real test for him.
Like how do you stop a meth head?
Okay.
In Canada it's a lot harder to,
to enforce the law when you don't have a
gun.
You know,
if this was America,
they would have just executed that guy.
He'd be done short video.
Kind of sad because instead of having
like a wonderful,
almost three stooge asked video do
enjoy,
it would just be like drugged homeless
man was shot dead by Florida.
Me,
you know.
But instead we've got this wonderful
little and it gets better.
Folks.
Stay tuned.
I love the effort by this officer
though.
He's like,
you will not fucking escape me.
Meanwhile,
back at the ranch,
his,
uh,
his wife having decided to divorce him
is looking for an escape room.
She goes to the ceiling,
desperation.
My God.
Now this is like,
Dude,
how the hell did they capture this so
perfectly.
That's what makes me suspicious of it
being faked.
Like even get the ass shot in there and
the spandex and not saying that's
something that interests me.
Just simply stating that it is quite an
opportunistic shot.
Wow.
Where is she?
Where did she go?
Let's find out having a tussle and then
suddenly look who's back.
That's right.
The girlfriend,
she's back.
She's back.
Ladies and gentlemen.
And aren't we so glad that the Canadian
police force in this very moment aren't
armed and we can enjoy this video she
pops back up to.
It's just so beautiful.
She dude,
they must be dragged out of their mind
because she just lives like,
shrugged it off like it's nothing.
Let's get it.
Let's get a.
let's get a slow.
Definitely.
Let's go to quarter speed on this one
shelly.
So as you can see,
she's crawling around the attic space
trying to look for an hour and um,
maybe maybe she had second doubts.
Maybe she said,
you know what?
I do Love A.
Oh,
you think she was trying to do like an
aerial assault?
Yeah.
Here.
She's trying to help out but not quite,
not quite.
There's tennis balls rolling all over
the place,
man.
She was just unharmed.
Whatever they're on,
I'll have one please Christ.
I could use a little invincibility and
my life.
I could barely go up my stairs in the
evening,
but be that as it may.
She's not wearing shoes either,
which I think is interesting to point
out.
I know she is.
Well,
she's missing one shoe.
She is missing one shoe,
which is definitely worth pointing out.
I wonder if she's headed on over to the
peanut bags to try to defend her
boyfriend.
Stuck up on ammo stack up on ammo.
She's like,
listen,
I listen.
I don't know the guy.
I didn't do anything,
man.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then then,
then the real,
the real mf or show up and,
and put an end to this rodeo.
But wasn't that a thrill?
Wasn't that a thrill?
Ladies and gentlemen.
Truly a gift from Canada and I just
really want to reflect one more time on
an enjoy the fact that they are armed
with tasers and not live.
Maybe they are,
I don't know,
but they didn't shoot him.
So cheers to that.
Yeah.
What a thrill.
It was a beautiful thing,
man.
It's like.
Do you see what I'm saying though?
It's almost so perfectly arranged,
right?
That,
that I'm very.
I am so much suspicion,
but the way they eat shit,
you really can't fake that.
Right?
Like,
like how do you fake that?
That's a real spill for Shadi of fake
that Shit.
She can't.
She,
she's,
she's takes back to school shopping
sales very seriously.
That face when a,
that face when school papers 50 percent
off me.
Once when school supplies or 50 percent
off.
No.
Let's see.
That again.
Really can't get enough.
So one more for posterity.
This is totally me when I see that APM
has a special on school supplies.
This is me watching that all weekend
still cracks.
Well,
cheers to them.
You know what?
Nobody was hurt.
Nobody was murdered.
It was a beautiful.
Oh,
it's just every once in a while you get
a video that's just so,
so perfect.
Hmm.
All right,
well now I got that out of the way.
We should move on to the Tan con.
Now.
I know a lot of you guys probably been
following the Tanach on thing.
I think a lot of people have talked
about it by now,
so I don't want to get too much into the
nitty gritty.
Honestly,
what I was trying to do,
because I was going through all this
information last night and w and the
preceding week,
we just understand like what the hell
happened,
so I kind of have things bullet pointed.
We've got video clips,
I got pictures and I.
and I think there's,
there's a lot of interesting stuff in
here,
but most,
most importantly.
Well let's,
let's start from the beginning.
Okay,
let's,
let's start here.
This is a riveting story by the way.
This whole thing is just absolutely
fascinating and I haven't seen
fascinating on a while and trust me when
I say that mean you see fascinating.
Fascinating too.
That up quick.
So she.
So tanner was pissed that vidcon
heading,
given her featured creator badge in
previous years,
so she wasn't having that.
So she decided to start her own
convention that was inclusive for
everyone.
That's what she kept pressing does that
it was inclusive for everybody.
She sold these vip passes that said
featured creators on them.
It's like what?
Every person there is a feature creator,
featured fucking creator actually would
actually said,
fuck,
the actual official name is featured
fucking Korean.
That is so fucking cool.
Um,
but it's like,
dude,
let's be real.
She sold 5,000
tickets and they are all featured
creators.
Let's be real.
There's only one featured creator at
Tana Con Stamina.
She wasn't there apparently.
Um,
so Tana decides to throw a con to rival
vidcon with like 30 to 45 days to plan
it.
All right,
so here,
here's the original invite from the
production company called good times,
which a lot of good info about these
boys.
But let's start with this welcome
creators.
We are so thrilled for you to be part of
the first ever Taneka on good times as a
family that celebrates the online
community.
We are so honored to be hosting this
event.
We truly believe that each of you here
is equipped,
are equipped with so many talents and
passions to lead a revolution to one
down,
Doug,
you're,
you're charging $65 for a VIP ticket.
There's not a revolution through the
social media world that foster the
vibrant,
inclusive and world changing
environment.
I hate this whole sentiment of like
everybody's a featured fucking creator.
You're all youtube superstars there.
It's actually really exploitive because
you know,
every kid these days wants more than
anything.
It'd be a utuber at my con.
Everybody's a featured fucking creator
for $65.
This event is pioneering the change that
we are community wish to see in this
industry.
Oh yeah,
we definitely need more,
more Tana cons.
We strive to make this a community where
everybody feels seen,
heard,
understood,
and most importantly included.
Don't they understand it?
In a world where everybody's included,
it's like you don't exist,
Tana,
when everybody's equal and everyone has
the same talents and appeal,
it's like you don't exist.
It's so disingenuous.
Everyone is a featured fucking creator.
So with that being said,
fuck vidcon.
Fuck the current CEO,
is this voice working for you?
It was a cringy.
I mean,
it's no more grungier than her boys.
That's fact.
Everyone who created vidcon and if you
want to know why Tannic comp became
thing and that's why other love,
right?
This is a great genesis of like a great
mission statement.
It's so phony,
dude.
It's the funniest shit ever.
You're all featured creators.
I gotta tell you,
I,
you've got probably noticed we don't
really post videos on h three anymore.
I just,
I'm so like,
well,
there's a lot of reasons why were were,
but one of the big reasons,
just like,
man,
I just,
I really just can't watch everything on
youtube.
It's just,
I don't know man.
It's all gotten.
So Tana,
it's like all Tana and people like her.
So,
um,
let me see what we got here.
Yes,
that's the window.
That's the floor.
What is this?
The dog?
I'm not sure what this significant of
that one is.
What does this stand first of all from
Shane's documentary documentaries?
A clip of her blog.
I think that video is just,
for some reason timestamp wrong.
Just go to the very beginning of that
video and it,
it,
it's a nice little summary of her,
uh,
her mission statement,
all of the rebels people and all of the
unwanted people should host a little
meet and greet in Anaheim,
California on the same days as a bit
gone.
I'd love to do it.
I would love
you all $65 to come to this rebellious
little convention of ours,
which stick it to them.
We'll stick it to those capitalists at
Vidcon.
It gets so good.
So anyway,
she's selling.
So what she actually pitches is that
most of the tickets are going to be free
and there's only going to be a few VIP
tickets.
What is essentially a free event?
People who buy VIP tickets get to skip
the line.
They get three times worth the ticket
price and a goody bag.
So the VIP tickets were $65.
So essentially she's saying the goody
bags can be worth about 200 bucks.
Okay.
So let's go ahead and look through the
goody bag that the VIP people get.
And guys really stick around here.
So this,
this was the most prominent,
probably the most valuable item.
And there went the Fuck I paid $20 for a
condom.
The condom.
Oh yeah.
Seventy five guns.
Dyslexic.
So it looks like a,
it's kind of packaged like an after
dinner mint.
You know,
what's the best part about them giving
out condoms?
Is that everyone?
There's 12.
That's good.
But also imagine actually using this
condom and then finding out that it
doesn't,
it's not a real condom breaks.
You know what I mean?
Like is there a little disclaimer that's
like,
this is actually an after dinner mint
packaging and not meant to conceal up
something as important as a condom.
I wonder how many like uh,
unplanned births or,
or infectious diseases were passed
thanks to her Tana condom by the way.
And it's so good that like con,
the Tan con,
it's just like,
so good.
Anyway,
that was the,
that was basically the highlight of the
good of the $200.
Goodie bag.
Um,
here's a video of a girl on boxing.
Her Goodie bag
stickers.
Kida Kida.
Not from family guy.
Pete.
It's sounds sponsored by Jason Nash.
But he's nowhere to be found good
princess,
but I can't afford that because I wasted
my money on a ticket.
Love it.
They included some broke ass.
Gucci Princess,
Ninety nine cent like wristband.
Like okay.
That's so Gucci Princess.
Do you think that any of these little
girls spending $65 for a vip pass can
afford Gucci?
Fuck,
I don't even know what this is.
Cozy free shopping guy.
Clearly it's just a bunch of garbage.
I mean it's essentially they basically
put a bunch of shit in a bag and said,
well you throw this out for us.
So.
But it gets good folks here.
Let's,
let's keep going.
So the day of it's pure chaos outside.
Nobody gets into the convention,
which turns out to be,
by the way,
just a Marriott events room that has a
maximum capacity of a thousand and the
creators can't even get into the room
because it's so unsafe because it's so
chaotic and uncontrolled outside.
Carol,
let me give you a view of basically
here.
Let's see.
This doesn't look.
So yeah,
you can see there's just like a winding.
It's like the whole parking lot.
I mean,
nobody can get inside.
No,
it's.
There's like 4,000
people outside or something like that.
Yeah,
so the funny part about basically this
is that thousands of people are outside.
Okay.
And they're supposed to be a VIP ticket
line for people who got the VIP ticket
to skip in front of the free tickets.
But everybody out there who's waiting in
line for four to six hours in the
blazing heat without any food or water
being offered,
there's actually footage of ambulance
and fire trucks coming and rescuing
people from getting each stroke.
Everybody who's outside is starting to
realize
they all have a VIP ticket because it
was pitched like mostly free and maybe
like 300 vip for people who really care
and want to make sure they meet
everyone.
So everybody out there,
they're starting realized has a VIP
ticket.
Um,
they start claiming that there was
20,000
people outside.
This is the genius that organized the
event.
This fucking 20 year old.
I don't even know what to say about you
did.
I can't really say anything honestly.
Can't say anything,
but what do you need to say?
What really do you need to say,
this is the guy that organized this
event.
What really do you need to say about a
guy like this?
Yup.
All as Dan affectionately put it,
the segway kid,
and this is just perfect.
This is.
This is the guy organizing the event.
This fucking guy with a scarf like,
oh yeah.
Once I put a scarf on,
everybody's going to know that this is
under control.
Except you made a huge mistake.
You drove a fucking segway around,
dude.
God,
Gee Whiz,
man.
This is a guy in charge.
Something special about the scarf when
it's like 95 degrees outside and people
are passing out from heat stroke.
Yeah,
totally.
exactly.
So they start gloating,
so it's,
it's chaos.
It's pandemonium outside.
Nobody can get in.
People are having heat stroke,
you know,
and they're start to.
Tana starts tweeting Shit like there's
20,000
people outside.
We only 5,000
people were to show we're supposed to
show up,
but there's 20,000,
15,000
unregistered guests showed up to the
convention and that's why we have to
shut it down here.
She says that Bella,
Bella and I are coming out to talk to
everyone.
Everything is fine.
Just fire marshal stuff,
keeping it safe.
Maybe I won't do that voice adding a
third day or if worse comes to worse,
I will be down to personally refund
anyone who still upset,
no one expected.
20,000
people in my loves.
I love you.
So she's just like,
Eh,
no big deal.
20,000
people showed up.
Everyone understands.
But the thing is that the police report
issued that same day says there was
4,000,
four to 5,000
people there at Max,
um,
four to 5,000
people at Max,
which turns out is the exact number of
VIP tickets they sold.
So literally the same amount of people
showed up as bought tickets and they're
trying to paint it like 20,000
people showed up and that's why we're
shutting it down.
But the truth is they oversold the
convention with a 1000 seat capacity to
5,000
people.
Here's the police report,
because Tana and his production company,
he kept trying to spin this narrative of
like so many people show up.
That's why we had to shut it down,
so here's the actual official police
report.
Garden Grove Police Department officers
were sent to Marriott suites to assist
hotel staff and security with crowd
control and dispersal of unruly hotel
guests from the hotel property.
The tanach con convention was an event
hosted by Tannic on company at the
Marriott Suites Hotel.
The organizing group for Tenneco was a
company called good times promotion.
Promotions event was scheduled to have
meet and greet sessions between youtube
celebrities in their fans.
There were concert concerts and dj
scheduled reform for fans in the bar
room starting at one or 10:00
AM.
10 ICAN had sold approximately 40,000
tickets at the time of the event.
The skip on down the hotel ballroom
where the event was scheduled could hold
a maximum of 1000 people.
The organized planned the organizers
plans to move the crowd in and out of
the venue to allow all attendees the
opportunity to participate in that.
As the crowd moved through the venue,
they were herded into the lobby after a
short time to allow other fans into the
ballroom.
People moved into the lobby.
We're upset and refuse to leave.
As the crowd grew in the lobby,
hotel staff and event security,
you cannot gain compliance from the
fans,
so they're like overflowing into the
hotel lobby.
But essentially what's important is that
the police specifically state that there
was four to 5,000
people there,
approximately 20 officers and several
supervisors responded to the scene.
Dude wasting the time of like
essentially an entire police force to
disperse this absolute mess.
The police supervisors on scene to
estimate the crowd was between four to
5,000
social media sites.
Had the crowd was 20,000
and this was not accurate.
The police officers were made,
were able to disperse the crowd after
approximately 60 to 90 minutes.
So there you go.
The exact amount of people showed up as
tickets sold.
Uh,
who could have predicted?
Yeah.
Who,
who would have ever seen that coming?
This is the part.
Oh wait,
I want to show this one scene.
Yeah.
This,
this is really important seeing here,
but this is from Shane's documentary,
which he,
he did a lot of the leg work on this and
it's really good,
but this is footage they took while they
were planning David their con.
So here,
listen to this,
but obviously I haven't said it 50 to
100 right now.
I love that.
For us,
I kind of just like set no capacity and
they're just like,
okay,
we're going to sell out.
We sell now because I feel like there's
a chance
everything about God,
I love that for us.
So he's like,
the hotel is set at a thousand but I
have it set at $5,200
and she bears witness to that and says I
love that for us,
which is basically conspiracy to commit
fraud.
But there is straight up just
acknowledging that they're overselling
the,
the event by 40,000
seats.
This is the part at the end of Shane's
documentary where he's just like,
here's the,
here's the raw facts.
So here you go.
So I still had a lot of questions about
pretty much everything.
So I called Michael and Michael's dad
the,
uh,
is the event organizers.
Yeah.
The segway kit,
that's the official number of VIP
tickets sold was 5,108.
The number of free tickets was between
two and 300
clusivity baby.
We just think that everybody's a
featured fucking creator as long as you
pay me $65.
I'm surprised 300 people get free
tickets.
Claims that Tana knew that and that she
was lying when she was at.
She still says she didn't.
The number of security guards,
was it never 91.
I got ahold of the contract and it said
that at most there was 25 security
guards kind of put that in perspective
for most conventions.
It's usually 50 guards per 5,000
people.
So this was cut in half.
The amount of money spent on security
was $60,000.
To put that in perspective,
the amount of money that they'd gone
spend on security is $1,000,000,000.
This is the big one.
So I got ahold of the contract between
the Marriott and good times and the
contract stated that there was only
going to be 1000 people in Michael
signed,
not Tana and Michael about this.
And they both said that yes,
the contract might've said it a thousand
dollars,
but everybody at Mary I've told them
that that was just the safe number in
that $5,000.
Okay.
That's so stupid.
There's,
they literally had a room with a max
capacity.
You,
you've worked with like um,
with a lot of venues and stuff.
If they tell you,
oh yeah,
they're like,
it's a thousand maximum capacity,
but that's just no fucking way.
Are you kidding me?
No Way.
No way in hell.
That's real.
Just also.
But that's kind of a big fucking
difference from 1000,
like maybe 1300 bucks,
100 over maybe.
But even then though,
they would never,
they would,
even,
if they would like turn a blind eye to
it,
they would never say that because
they're liable like that.
That's insane.
It's Marriott,
it's a huge corporation and not going to
be like,
oh yeah,
5,000.
That's fine,
that's the part.
It's Mario,
it's not some amateurs,
small hotel and they don't give a fuck
about Tana,
you know,
like they do.
They have events there every day.
It's,
this is just routine to them and there's
just no,
there's no way that's real.
I mean this,
this is the part that really gets like
hearing saying the capacity is 1200.
Even if there was no issues,
no drama,
no whatever.
It wouldn't have worked.
There's no way that 5,000
people could fit there.
There is no way that 5,000
people would have had this wasn't gonna
work,
but what is capacity
talk.
But obviously I haven't said it.
Fifty 200 right now.
I love that for us.
I also though capacity,
why she'd been looking there like a mom,
you know,
she's 20.
That blew me away.
She's 20.
She looks like she's going on her second
marriage already.
Just like,
okay,
we're going to sell out.
We sell
coked out.
She was like rubbing or no,
I feel like there's a chance everything
about this.
So anyway,
the thing that that really like just
actually irks me about this is that
Shane,
Shane did an amazing job on this
documentary,
like showing all this.
I mean he did not pull punches,
but in a way it is also a way for them
to save face and be like,
we confronted it,
we talked about it,
but the truth is they straight up appear
to be committing a fraud.
They collected like $325,000
from these kids.
The convention,
by the way,
completely shut down like nobody got in.
And here's the great part.
Nobody's been refunded,
nobody's been refunded here.
Check out this press release.
Apparently this g,
the segway kid,
the genius in a contract he signed with
this startup,
a ticketing company said that they will
not issue refunds any,
any under any condition,
and the any refunds would be have to be
handled by them directly.
It's a great policy.
It's fantastic.
And then here,
if you would,
we'll be issuing refunds to make a
claim.
Please go to good times.live/claims
and fill out the form anytime before
January fifth.
You should expect a refund within the
next 30 days.
It's like Bro,
you gotta you gotta jump through hoops
and pray that you get a refund,
but the worst part is like a lot of
people flew there booked hotel rooms for
this and these guys are pretty much
committed like a straight up criminal
fraud.
I would not be surprised if the FBI
police come knocking at their door and
like a couple of weeks.
So I don't know.
Yeah,
there's no way this is over for them.
I don't think so.
They're in deep shit.
Yeah.
There's some great little details here
to like the same night that that all
went down and the convention was closed
and everyone was losing their minds.
Walking from venue to venue crying,
trying to find something else.
Is that the
11:00
PM?
We're still calling venues.
It's 2:00
AM.
We're still calling.
You know,
Martina asked 71 party.
Look at this.
This is her that evening.
Sure.
What do you want to do?
Do you want to.
Okay,
thanks for your $65
anyway.
So why bother?
You know,
what really shocked me the most,
because you know,
this girl Bella Thorne that she's
friends with,
they're both 20 dude.
That's more mind blowing than even the
fraud itself.
Those girls and I,
I don't know if this comes off road,
it might,
but.
And they're,
those girls have a lot of mileage on
them.
They're like 20 going on 30,
like Holy Shit.
And I'm not saying that like Bella
Thorne isn't attractive.
I'm just saying she needs her oil
changed at this point.
I'm 20 years old.
I think she looks good.
She looks good.
It just looks like she's.
She just washed out of the sea.
Tana.
Oh my.
I don't know.
I just shocked that she's 20.
I'm not saying that they're ugly or
anything.
Just God damn.
Well that explains a lot about all of
this.
And I believe,
uh,
the Michael Kidd,
the segway kid.
He,
he's also 20 or maybe 21.
What happened is a bunch of children.
Yeah.
What happens when a bunch of 20 year old
pseudo celebrities try to organize a
convention?
Here it is.
You get a little fraud,
a little unplanned pregnancy.
A couple of,
uh,
stds.
Have you ever had a condom break on you,
Dan?
I have actually.
Yeah.
That's scary.
That's a bad feeling.
A lot of people are going to be busting
through those.
Did breaking through a con.
It's one of the worst things ever.
I remember the first time I had sex and
the condom broke the first time.
The very first shit.
And you're like,
oh shit.
You're like,
this is a good condom.
this is a really good condom.
Damn.
What's this brand again?
Damn baby.
What's this brand?
Oh,
it's a Tan AECON brand.
Like,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
Do you have to plan B it?
Beat it,
beat it.
The time the condom broke.
That was the one time.
Yeah.
Tana contract probably have included a
low plan being her goodie bag just in
case I needed a plan B for this
convention.
Her parents needed a plan B if I'm being
honest.
Yikes.
So anyway,
it turns out the con and Tana con as has
a double meaning in this casing as both
a convention and a literal con.
So I have a couple of bonus clips for
you guys.
There's really nothing to say,
but I felt stupid even talking about it.
Honestly.
It's,
it's fascinating in that it was such a
train wreck and presumably they put this
event together almost without even a
thought to what would actually happen
the day of,
you know what I mean,
like so irresponsible that sent 5,000
fucking people and almost a not even
like they thought as long as I booked
the room,
it's like,
you know,
if you build it,
they will come.
That was a movie you need.
You need another audience out there.
Yeah.
I don't know.
You need.
Anyway.
It was just like mind numbingly insane.
Um,
would not be surprised if a week we see
some jail time for them.
If I'm being.
And I'm,
and I swear to God,
I'm being honest.
We're not.
Be surprised.
Well the big thing is this Michael Guy,
at least according to Shane's
documentary,
he signed on the dotted line for
everything.
Yeah.
But.
So He's,
he's definitely fucked.
The thing is,
I think she,
that one clip alone proves that she has
like a conspiracy to commit fraud.
I love that.
For us,
that is going to play in a courtroom.
There's going to be a judge and a jury
at watching 10 ago.
I love that for us,
and then the judge is going to be like,
you know what?
I love for you five to 10 years.
I'm trying to think of a good plan where
I'm trying to.
You know what I love for you Tana?
Sixty five months.
One month for every dollar for your VIP
ticket.
By the way,
bonus.
In my research I found some.
She's either.
Why does she exist?
Why is she popular?
Hey guys,
it's Tana.
You know what's so stupid about like
youtube,
like she like they complete.
I haven't ran about too,
but I don't fucking.
I don't give a shit.
Why is it that Youtube will not even bat
an eye at me or dubs or any of my
friends that actually have.
I'm not going to say they have talent.
They deserve shows.
What the fuck is it always Tana and
people like her who are actually not
only the lowest character,
but frankly criminals
that,
that get youtube red series.
Like there was a,
um,
she was featured in this.
Joey got fucking dog at show is so dumb.
The haunted house show God.
Have you.
Have you ever seen anything dahmer?
I,
I dare you to watch this shit.
And A,
and in a way youtube is enabling them
to,
it'd be like,
you are stars.
So they're running ads for Tanna.
I've got this add a bunch of times
because she's premiered in the new
season of Joe are Cephas fucking shitty
house.
And it says,
do you love Tana?
Like Youtube is actually running ads
promoting this,
this mom.
I say,
mom,
because like I said,
it looks like she's going on her second
marriage.
She looks like a mom that doesn't spend
a lot of time with their kids.
You know what I mean?
She looks like a mom who's out at 3:00
AM,
partying and grandma takes care of the
kids.
You know what I mean?
Does she not look like that?
They should not look like this.
The odometer is just about to hit
100,000,
you know,
the check engine light is on.
So anyway,
and somehow I'm unendorsed bubble or
like my friends who,
who,
who I respect to my great content.
Probably the best on youtube.
They're unendorsed but somehow.
But anyway,
so I'm,
I'm on her vlog channel,
right?
This is her trailer,
Bro.
Watch this.
This is her trailer watch in a few
hours.
Hunter and I just took some adderall.
No,
we did not.
Can you not say that?
No,
I didn't think that's her fucking first
message to her fans.
This 20 year old with these little
girlfriends.
Her first thing she wants you to know
about her is that she just took drugs
illegally.
I just took adderall.
Can I not say that?
She's probably the one that left it on
the floor and two boys and shredder.
Oh,
interesting.
She got wind that we were doing this
today.
Preemptive strike.
Let's give Tana a show on youtube.
Red called how called how to be damaged
goods by the age of 22.
Let's,
let's give Tana a show a reality show on
youtube.
Red called how to poison the minds of
the young generation under the guise of
family friendly content.
Her a show.
Let's do it.
Oh,
oh.
But kids like her.
Let's give her a shill.
Kids watch her.
Okay.
She's in.
I just took adderall and I sprinkled it
on.
Ethan's Florida poison his dog.
Um,
I lost track of time.
How long have you been with Stanford for
break?
I have one more.
I have one more clip.
All right.
Um,
his clips.
Not that important.
Let's go to the break.
All right.
I got worked up.
I need to go.
Cool off guys.
We've got a commercial and after that
we've got a lot to get to,
including we've got prank calls that
somebody did with my voice.
Someone made a soundboard.
Blind voice.
We've got.
I want to talk about the KSI versus
Logan.
Paul fight so much more.
Oh,
see you guys soon.
Electric toothbrush.
Legend has it.
This toothbrush fell from the sky on the
eve of Jesus's birth.
Christmas Day.
The shot from the sky like immediate.
Right?
But it was not destroyed.
Quip is the best toothbrush ever
invented by a mortal man.
But the toothbrush itself is immortal.
Here's what it does.
It's electric.
It's slick,
it's handy,
it vibrates,
but it's just a little guy.
And guess what?
It only costs you about 25 bucks to get
started with an electric toothbrush.
You put it in,
it vibrates a cleaned your teeth.
It's got a nice soft bristle,
unlike any other toothbrush.
I'm telling you folks,
do you listen to?
The angels are crying.
They're not singing,
they're crying because this is a
miracle.
That's why it's on Oprah's O,
o list.
Nobody just gets on Oprah's list.
Here's what it does.
It vibrates and it pulsates,
and it tells you when to switch to the
bottom side.
At times you you're supposed to brush
for three minutes.
I bet you don't get sick.
Nasty freak.
Your mouth stinks.
Not Anymore.
Brush,
brush,
vibrates.
Switch,
brush,
brush.
All the sudden you're done.
You brushed enough.
Your gums are healthy,
your mouth is glowing,
your breath is incredible.
And those angels that are crying for you
right now,
they're gonna.
Be crying for the nice smell in your
mouth because finally,
a girl's not going to have to smell your
stinky breath and that makes angels cry.
Enjoy.
Quip starts at just $25.
If you got to get quip.com/h
three right now,
you'll get your first refill pack for
Reid with a quip electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill.
Pack free@getequIp.com
slash h three.
Get quip.com/h
three.
Get it so that angels will cry for you.
Tears of joy.
You hear that?
That's the sound of a swab.
Asked Dollar Shave Club using dude
walking down the street looking clean.
He's radiant,
he's clean shave.
He smells good.
And everybody who walks by and says to
themselves,
I want to suck that guy's Dick.
That's right.
Dollar Shave Club folks.
Dollar Shave Club delivers everything
you need to look,
feel and smell your very best.
You name it.
Shampoo,
conditioner,
body wash,
toothpaste,
hair,
Gel.
Even a wipe that will leave your Tush
theone,
Tingley and clean.
And let me tell you folks,
when they say Tingley,
they mean it,
and I mean that in the best way
possible.
You want your anal hole tanglin.
I'm a big fan of their amber and
lavender calming body wash.
This body wash is incredible.
Have you ever rolled through a field of
lavender?
Well,
it's thorny and it's awful and I
wouldn't recommend it,
but with the soap,
you get that beautiful smell without
having to run through a bunch of brush.
It smells amazing.
It's a beautiful thing.
Good luck.
Finding a product like that in the store
probably costs you five to $6,000.
All of dollar shave club products are
made with top shelf ingredients that
won't break your budget.
You will feel the difference.
Plus shipping is included with your
membership.
And here's a great way to try dollar
shave club's product for just five
bucks.
You can get their daily essential
starter kit.
It comes with the body wash,
the oneweb trolley,
the.
They're amazing,
but wipes that we talked about at the
tingling sensation on the anal hole.
I don't want say anal,
the anus anusol as much sexier than
Anna's folks and of course the world
famous shave butter.
We got Woo's backstage folks and of
course the best razors.
This six blade executive,
I don't have my suit and tie on,
but I've got my executive.
Keep the blades coming for just a few
more bucks a month and add in shampoo,
toothpaste,
or anything else you need for the
bathroom.
Check it all out@dollarshaveclub.com
slash h three.
That's dollar shave club.com/
[inaudible].
Guys,
give it a shot.
It's convenient.
Come straight to your door.
It's higher quality than what you find
in the store and it's two people are to
want to suck.
Hit me with that music then,
and people when they pass you on the
street are going to want to
Dan.
Oh no,
that's no.
That took way too long then.
There's no reason not to join.
Get Yours@dollarshaveclub.com
slash [inaudible] three today.
Give it a shot.
If you have not played fort night yet.
Let me ask you this.
What the hell are you doing with your
life?
This game is a phenomenon.
Taking the.
It's probably,
I think,
I'm not sure,
but it's probably.
I think it's the most popular game ever
made the most active players.
There's 125 million players.
That's insane.
That's like half the continental United
States.
You guys get on there.
You might match up against Ninja.
You know the world famous East Sports
Gamer that's taken world by storm.
Here's some gameplay right here.
This could be you right now for night is
a pvp of 100 players,
distractible environment,
buildable structures,
and you can play with your friends and
duos and squads.
They are consistently releasing new
content and cool new features every day.
That's true.
This game is always evolving and being
updated.
The developers care so much.
Such a great,
polished,
fun experience of a game.
There's a reason it's so popular,
folks.
It's because it's freaking awesome.
It's like the best genre,
the battle,
the battle royale meets the best
developers who have completely polished
it,
are putting so much love and care into
it every day.
What's not to love and here's the
craziest,
trippy as part.
It's free.
It's 100 percent free to play.
Yeah,
I know.
It's insane.
For nights constantly.
Did you guys know that season five is
right around the corner?
Did you see the rocket that was launched
last week?
I wonder what that's all about.
There's a rocket.
You better sign up to play.
Make sure you guys jump in before season
five starts on July twelfth and it's
available on almost every platform.
I'm talking Ios,
PC,
Mac,
playstation four,
xbox one,
and switch.
And guys,
if I can't sing praises anymore about
fortnight,
it's freaking cross play like what game
has ever achieved?
Actual Cross play.
The meaning that if you're on your pc,
you could play with somebody on on the
playstation four.
What a click the link in the description
guys,
to see what the hype is all about.
Play.
Fight fortnight for free.
So go to Lincoln description.
Give it a shot.
I mean,
what do you got to lose?
Try play for an hour.
See if you like it.
If not deleted,
it's free.
What do you have to lose?
Thank you for it and I appreciate you.
Let's get back into it.
Welcome to the experience.
Can I get some lightning bolts?
Joe Rogan step off,
bitch.
That's right.
You think I could take Joe Rogan and an
arm wrestling match?
Do you want a real answer?
Does he have lightening bolts stand yes
or no?
As far as I know.
No.
So probably the same answer as if I
didn't know.
I didn't know lightning was allowed in
an unprecedented.
I mean if it is,
then you got it in the bag.
No problem.
Alright,
easy.
Um,
let's get it here.
Just like the,
uh,
just like the store we saw experience
that feels good.
Just like the clip we saw earlier of
these Canadian crackheads falling
through the roof.
There's another great one that I want to
throw up here.
This Guy Lou Walsh.
Okay.
You creepy fucking loony tune.
This was a clip.
I guess it happened several years ago.
Lou Welsh from thex factor.
I mean we're all talking about like me
too and all this shit.
Like if you,
if you blink,
if you blink wrong at a girl,
you're going to be deposed.
Ethan answered truthfully.
Did you look from the peripheral vision
down?
Uh,
her skirt down her or low cut top.
The camera caught your pupils looking
slightly to the left.
Okay.
And this world,
I don't know if that's a good example of
whatever.
Do you guys,
do you ever look at girls through your
peripheral vision?
Dan,
do you like this?
I don't think any guys pretty tricky.
Oh yeah.
I mean that's.
You do that.
I've never,
I don't know that I can't say I've ever
done this.
Really?
You've never come on.
You see that ground in anyway.
I think you already went to sleep.
You can.
You can tell the truth.
I've never,
I don't.
But I'll tell you.
Who Does Lou Walsh look at this fucking
Sicko
got today.
She makes now she knows she's.
Yeah.
It's not the same show that Ryan
seacrest was a fuck is wrong.
All right,
well she's clearly discuss it.
She's not kidding around it.
How the hell did nothing come from this?
Like this clip resurfaced recently of
him.
Basically,
and by the way,
why do you have to do it live on
television?
Is that somehow like the end,
the lion's den theory,
right?
Like safest and in plain sight.
Yeah.
Maybe the other might be kind of like,
who's going to say something?
To me that's like the secrets thing too,
when he approaches Katy Perry,
it's like,
why the fuck are you going to make these
creepy comments to her right before you
come live?
Because it's almost like the safest time
to do it,
right?
Because they don't want to,
you know,
they're going to cause a scene by
getting upset by it.
You know,
it's not embarrassing.
What is wrong with you?
Like,
what is it?
It's clearly not sexual satisfication.
It really is almost like a power play.
Totally.
Explain what's going on for the,
uh,
for the audio listeners.
Oh,
well,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Them,
they felt while he's sitting on a couch,
it during the live broadcast has of the
x factor.
He's got his hand on the cohost ass.
He squeezing it and patting it live on
TV.
She's getting noticeably irritated.
And she finally says,
basically,
what are you
here?
I still have a job.
Like that's a creepy shit I ever seen
him.
By the way,
why is this guy looked like a fucking
baby bites his face looked like a little
child that never aged.
Just be like his skin degenerated like
he aged,
but he never grew up.
That's you,
Lou Walsh.
Shitload of Botox,
right?
Probably a lot of children's for skin.
You know,
they say children's for skin is the most
regenerative.
A potent,
you know,
cosmetic.
He probably.
They say that.
Actually I'm not.
I'm not kidding that shit.
No,
I swear to God,
but I'll tell you.
Lou Walsh,
this is a powerful man.
He's got a lot of money.
He's got the.
He's got the literal face of a child.
You probably has baby for skin factory.
You know how they like a farm silk.
This guy farms for skinny.
He's probably got babies on chains and
he and they've got super regenerative
for skin.
They're like a new breed.
And they got super regenerative for skin
that he just snips and rubs.
He actually what?
He rubs his shoe.
The shoe magma,
not actually the force can buttons.
This magma is the residue and dirt that
collects when you don't clean inside the
force gun.
The other problem I have because I'm
Jewish,
but he probably does rub that magma
oliver his fucking face and that's why
it looks like that.
That's why it looks like a 50 year old
gerber baby.
I always hated that guy's face added
even more know what a piece of shit and
he's like,
he's doing the groping and then like the
moment where she finally reacts.
He's just like jiggling it.
Like he's just like,
it's a man's world baby.
Why is this guy still have a job?
That's my question because I found this
clip and it just resurface.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is like really bad and I'm looking
at.
I'm looking and I'm trying to find any
evidence of,
of him being reprimanded for this and
there's nothing there.
Nothing happened.
Nothing.
We need to.
We need to go to his home.
When he to look in his basement,
you know that there's like giant bottles
of milk and these super regenerative
force can babies in his basement.
He selling these two Chinese patrons,
they used them as Viagra.
The Chinese will do anything to help
stimulate their sex and you know I'm
right.
All the fuckers straight up kill
endangered species,
Rhino Horn baby to to help get their
dick hard.
It doesn't work by the way,
but they still kill them all and I'm
sure you tried it until you try it.
I Rhino Horn.
Well,
as far as I can tell,
there is no medical value and ground up
toenails,
which is basically what it is.
But I love that.
The Chinese to go on a little tangent,
it's like you know that there's Viagara
right?
You don't have to go fucking kill
endangered species anymore.
And Lou Walsh,
it's time to just age with grace and
shut down the baby force can factory.
This guy pisses me off,
man.
It's pretty gross.
When was this?
This is like some,
you know that scarf.
You seen his vest pocket.
That's his fucking jerk off rag.
He's such a Weirdo.
He probably goes to the bathroom during
the break.
Jerks and do is rack,
puts it back in his pocket.
He probably does weird shit like makes
her smell it without telling her.
He goes eight falls out of his bag.
He's like,
oh,
can you pick that up for me?
Because he gets off and knowing that she
touched his comrades.
Jesus Christ,
man.
He's a Sicko.
It's not man.
Fuck this guy.
Yeah,
I guess this was.
This is pretty.
Pretty Harvey.
Pretty hard to get away with this.
We're in a post harvey world and I just
saw this video man and I gotTa tell you
I did not like it.
This is the same show that like.
See Chris Scott and we're in.
We're in trouble over though,
right?
Without America.
No,
that's all circling around.
Simon.
Cow Cow.
He is the epicenter.
Simon cows up to some weird shit.
By the way,
baby for screen is just the beginning
with Simon cowl.
That's just the tip of the Dick.
Simon cow.
What does he do?
You know?
These rich billionaires have the most
fucking twisted like fetishes because
like nothing gets you off at that level
of wealth and power.
What does Simon callow get off on?
[inaudible]?
I'd like to know.
He just beats people to death for sport.
He just grinds up bodies and then puts
them into a sausage tubing and fucks
himself with it.
That's vulgar.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Maybe that's all right.
Let's move on.
We dissect it.
I think that's accurate though.
Just for the record.
Look at his face.
I wouldn't be surprised if he shoving,
you know,
body parts of his ass.
What else would get along?
I get him off.
Does he react at all during this clip?
What is his reaction to.
I think he looks disgusted.
Oh,
I don't know that he saw necessarily.
Right?
Like I don't.
I don't.
I don't think he necessarily knows
everyone's joking around because they
didn't see how free that's going to be
really frustrated for
her.
It takes a lot of courage to on live TV
and be like,
hold on.
Oh yeah,
fuck yeah.
And nobody saw what happened.
So it's hard to be supportive of her
right in that moment that the on the
couch don't necessarily see how severe
it is.
Just God bless her,
you know,
and God bless her.
That's all I can say.
All right,
fuck no,
that's moving on.
She does spice girl in my heart.
She's got a lot of spice and she has a
spice girl.
It's confirmed,
confirmed spice girl there.
So,
um,
we announced a giveaway last week for
the way a lot of people submitted songs
about Ian.
The end turn.
We got a lot of great submissions,
but there was one that really rised
above a.
Oh shit.
I have to play it.
God dammit.
Can you play it?
Yeah,
actually I got it ready.
Hold on.
So there was one song that really rised
above made by Jan occasion.
It's a beautiful little diddy that
expresses my inner feelings on the
Internet.
Sometimes he's,
he,
you know,
he's there and he tries his best,
but goddammit.
And so God,
goddammit,
Cajun Cajun,
and I'm giving you what are you giving
them?
Beautiful s nine plus.
Oh boy,
this is the best phone on the market
folks.
And let me tell you what,
I got a special twist open.
I got a special little incentive.
Goddammit,
didn't you weren't supposed to
procreate.
God dammit.
Oh,
it opens this way.
there you go.
That's so in my bed and you were
supposed to coach me on how to open this
box.
And this is the one that I'm.
This is the,
this is.
Okay.
This is yours.
Comes with my DNA.
Cajun Cajun grants.
You can you comes with my kiss marks and
my DNA.
So that's going out to the Cajun Cajun.
And there's another person I want to
give an award on,
a phone to my favorite phone on the
market.
By the way,
Samsung has graciously supported us.
They've given us what they send us.
10 of these 10,
something like that.
Look at you.
Notice this fucking beautiful new TV.
Samsung's hooking it up and supporting
us,
which is great because they're pacing my
favorite tech company.
Um,
we're going to keep giving these away.
What is this like a thousand dollar
phone given that.
So what's,
what's the retail value?
Let's look it up a lot.
Samsung Galaxy,
so I am going to give away another phone
to this.
This one guy,
he submitted a prank call that he made
with my voice.
He called a health food store and he
made a soundboard of my voice when I was
talking about Keto Diet and the call is
pretty good.
It's not like genius,
but I love that he created this really
specific soundboard of me talking about
Keto and my hope is that by.
I want to watch with you guys.
It's a lot of fun.
I want more shit from you guys.
I want soundboards.
I prank calls.
I want parody songs.
I want everything cool.
Send it goddammit to
podcast@hthreehthreeproductions.com.
We're going to show it.
We're going to credit you and our
favorite ones,
our favorite ones are getting hooked up
with my DNA.
That's also on an SDM plus.
You can choose to not have DNA,
but I think most of you are going to
want some of my baby for skin.
I am one of the super regenerative
babies.
Magic being a baby with Super Regena to
for skin DELAC escapes the factory,
but you're forced can keeps fucking
growing like it never stopped.
So wow.
You have to cut it like toenails.
You have to keep it on a monthly basis.
It's a monthly breast.
Yeah.
Did you know,
and this just occurred to me and I think
it's worth sharing and this is real,
that in Israel,
the very religious Jews have when they
have brisses and please,
I'm not kidding,
the rabbis know where this is going to
suck the baby's fucking Dick.
They cut the force going off and then
the rabbis suck the blood out of his
newly freshed fucking dig hygienic and a
lot of the times these nasty old fucks
have like herpes and they'll give the
fucking room what?
These guys are so insane.
These ultra religious guys,
like they tried to outline that,
that practice in Israel recently,
but it didn't pass because they're like,
listen,
if I want to suck a baby's Dick,
who are you to tell me now?
I wonder if he's trying to suck the
regenerative for you know,
stem cells.
Maybe.
Imagine,
imagine for a second damn,
putting a baby's bleeding dick in your
mouth.
I'm not going to imagine that.
Just imagine being that guy.
What the fuck man out here it goes.
Here it goes.
Nothing.
Imagine being.
That guy is insane.
These religious guys,
I'm telling you,
man,
they're from another planet entirely.
These,
these same cookie fucks.
There's some,
a Jewish holiday where they grab a
chicken and fucking spin it around over
their fucking heads until it like shit's
everywhere and it's just sprang shit
everywhere.
And then when they're done,
they go suck a baby's bleeding thick.
These are the French,
by the way.
This is not right.
This is like they're out there.
Yeah.
It's basically like the Judaism version
of like the um,
what those limit ticks that like always
causing a scene at like,
uh,
oh,
the funerals in the Baptist church.
Just like,
Bro.
Yeah.
Westborough.
I can see them.
I like to see them square off the
insane,
insane battle.
I think I got to be frank.
I think the Jews in this case,
when you think so well,
they got the vitality from the baby for
skin,
so it's hard to top sucking a baby's
bleeding.
Dick can't really top that and I and I
feel bad even saying it.
Folks,
can I call you folks anyway?
Let's play the song.
So the prank song by are the prank call
by.
Sound mastered.
Tony,
go ahead and roll it down so I'm must
have.
Totally.
Here we go.
Turn it up.
Excuse me.
Can you help me with something?
Sure.
Can you be kind and take the time to
help me out?
What are you showing visually right now?
Your beautiful face.
That's going to be awkward.
What you want?
I guess I don't know,
but I can just sit here for two minutes
and it's just showing them.
Feel like.
Just go wide.
I like that.
Yeah.
People love that shit.
Internalized depression.
Face here.
I'm going to play it on my computer.
Well,
this is Gina.
How can I help you?
Excuse me.
Can you help me with something?
Sure.
Can you be kind and take time out of
your day to help me?
How can I help you?
I'm going to be fully honest.
I don't understand the Keto Diet.
Uh,
well,
the Keto Diet is,
you know,
it's like,
have you heard of the,
a axis diet?
Yes.
Okay.
So it's going to be somewhat similar.
You have to be in the same pattern of
what it is that they need you to do and
then they have their products that you
can,
that will help you lose weight.
This whole thing of like don't eat fruit
just seems fishy to me.
Oh,
maybe I'm around.
Yeah.
No,
you know,
it's Kinda like you just eat a lot of
bacon and,
and meet,
you know,
nothing else.
So,
okay.
For breakfast,
eat eggs and cheese and bacon deep fried
and covered
canola oil.
Dramatica.
She doesn't bat an eye.
She's like,
Yep,
that's the dying your hair
that on that guy at a.
I would recommend talking with him.
He'll be back in the store on.
Do you feel like people hate fat people
know at the grocery store their sugar
and fucking everything?
Well that,
that,
that there is,
it's so easy for skinny people like you.
I crave and desire hamburgers and pizza.
Hm.
Well,
is it an issue of self control?
Yes,
it is.
I've always known that about fat and
skinny at the same time.
Huh?
I'm healthy at 400 pounds.
Well,
but if you'd like to talk,
you know,
talk more with John about that diet.
You're more than welcome to call back on
Friday.
I used to be fit.
Okay.
Are you actively still on the decline?
Weight Wise?
Uh,
are you asking me personally?
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah.
Is this going?
I don't remember if it goes anywhere.
I mean there's,
there's not a climax necessarily,
so you guys get the idea.
It's not a genius prank call,
but I love that he,
he sound boarded this Keto thing and
call it,
love it.
I want your guys stop.
Help me be funnier.
I'm not funny.
I don't have the time to make segments.
You make segments for us.
That's what I love.
Genius.
And frankly,
if you guys have a funny prank call or
maybe if it's neither unrelated to me
necessarily,
we want to hear it and if it's funny
we're going to use it and we're going to
you a fricking phone.
Not a bad deal.
So I looked it up.
It's about 950 bucks.
Whoa.
You can Ebay.
I won't judge you.
You're not gonna want to though once you
open it up obviously.
Alright,
we're alright.
Come on.
Oh,
here's a good one.
This is a good one.
You guys.
Ty Lopez.
Friend of the show.
But I mean let's do this.
Let's be honest.
Well I've,
I've said many,
many harsh things about the lead
throughout the years,
but I just love this Tai Lopez.
He's been doing these live streams and
he's so cocky about it because he's
live.
He's like,
yeah,
I can handle anything.
Give me a call.
And so he's giving these,
these lessons on real estate and someone
calls in and basically calls them out
and shuts down.
Tie live on stream.
Let's enjoy
alive.
What's up youtube?
We're doing a live debate.
I'm curious.
I'm actually curious about your real
estate jobs.
All right,
so give me the formula for a cap rate.
Can you define what a cap rate is?
So real.
Let's talk about real estate for a
second.
Let's.
No,
no,
no.
The find the formula of the cap rate.
Do you know what a cap rate is?
Absolutely.
He's like immediately trying to deflect
and for once this guy really hold them
to it.
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but I assume it's probably some
elementary thing that if you know
anything about real estate,
you should know what this is.
That's what I assume you crediting the
channel.
Dan.
This was made by Evan.
Judge put together by
Capri.
It's like Roi and the stock market.
They call it cap rate.
It's very similar formula or a Capri.
All right,
John,
can I say one thing about real estate?
You cannot teach a real estate course
and I love you bro.
Look at his face.
You can see that humiliation.
His eyes are squinted.
He's just like,
Damn.
All the slickness in the world die.
You've got your.
You understand Thai that your laptop is
on two books about Mark Twain and
economics on the bottom.
You really think you want me to believe
that you've read all three of those
books,
tie volume one and two.
The autobiography of Mark Twain tells me
one was Mark Twain born tie,
and then he goes,
let me tell you about Mark Twain.
Let's talk about huck Finn for a second.
Yeah,
exactly.
Jon,
but you cannot take a real estate course
if you can't tell me the formula of
account teacher who teaches my real
estate course.
John,
I don't know.
Oh,
sorry.
You don't know.
I don't teach my real estate course.
I interviewed the top real estate
investors that I know real estate after
you get started.
Ty is honestly and as a,
as a guy,
the honestly the master of bullshit.
What the fuck you want me to get that
out of there real quick?
He is the master of bullshit.
That was good,
man.
They held his feet to the fire and they
got them good.
Yup.
I want to get him on here.
I'm going to call tie and say.
Tell me about Mark Twain backed from the
two volumes of Mark Twain's
autobiography.
Tie.
Give me a freaking break.
I love Mark Twain.
I wouldn't read that shit,
but that's just me.
Alright.
Let's get to the putting the pudding
pie.
We've got a key lime pie.
It's fresh.
It's right.
I would say maybe an American Apple Pie.
Warm out of the oven.
Good enough to put your Dick in.
Apple Pie.
American pie.
I'm KSI versus Logan Paul.
Now I will say this.
I actually like Ksi.
I don't really have a problem with this
for you guys who don't know Logan.
Paul and everyone knows the Logan Paul's
case size sides a really big.
He was Scott,
big plank FIFA,
but he's kind of like the English pewdie
pie in a way.
He kind of just makes videos about
whatever.
He's very popular.
And um,
he recently had a boxing match with
another person who we won.
And now there's this whole big thing
about case I boxing logan.
Paul.
My favorite part about this.
It's such a circus.
I'm telling you,
I can't be on youtube.
It's,
this is what it's devolved into.
There's nothing genuine left with very
few channels of a genuine left.
Um,
it's very.
Anyway,
Ksi little brother comedy,
shorts,
Gamer,
and the undercard is boxing logan.
Paul's little brother Jake Paul.
Also a friend of the show also show.
So I don't,
I don't have a problem.
I actually liked those guys,
but this whole thing,
it was just such a circus.
Like let me show you.
They haven't fought yet,
but here's the press conference from,
from the event.
What are you going to do with.
I don't actually
volume on the youtube a little bit.
Do you don't have one idea that is going
to set up his camera.
I've got something familiar.
Logan.
Paul,
you're.
Who are you like one?
You're Mr.
suicide prevention and now you're Mr.
sit your ass bitch.
Sit your ass down.
Bitch.
The great white hope.
Just a white boy from Ohio.
I don't know what that means.
There was a movie called that.
I don't.
I don't know if I just made some racial
implications.
So strike that from the record,
but
it's like,
who are you guys?
Look at Logan and Jake Paul.
Like,
who the fuck are you?
There's nothing genuine about these
people.
They're flying in the wind.
They don't know who they are.
These are the people that youtube
selects to promote and highlight and
endorse and I don't know what it is by
nature.
It's almost like survival of the fittest
on Youtube.
It's like you have to be this
inauthentic,
a oil slick.
The floats in the water to rise to the
top is very rare.
Very few exceptions have youtube
channels that actually rise above,
um,
and,
and find success that are not this.
What the fuck is he saying,
Hey,
let me say this,
I'll just,
I'll keep this running because I really
don't even care what they're saying.
It's so obvious that they're pretending
to play a role.
Right?
I want to even be surprised from being
honest.
If these guys talked regularly on the
phone,
100 percent just colluding,
you know,
to make this the biggest event ever
because their whole thing is like,
this is going to be make rager averse.
Mayfield bigger.
That's how they're presenting it.
This is crazier.
I bet you these guys talk on the phone
and they just jerk off about how much
money they're gonna make and on one hand
I have to respect the brilliance of like
doing a boxing match.
I think it is somewhat of a brilliant
move,
but it's like Logan,
you're not like,
who the fuck are you dude?
Are you the lovable child entertainer?
Who cares about suicide prevention
or
are you a fucking.
I don't even know what he looks like.
He looks like
he looks like a door to door salesman
who's going bald at early age.
You know,
and this is,
this is the moment they live for where
everybody's rushing on stage.
You can't believe it.
Oh,
the tensions are high.
These two guys are going to kill each
other.
They really,
truly,
genuinely hate each other.
They're all meanwhile like fast forward
to this morning at 8:00
AM.
They're both on this on like the toilet.
Amen.
It's going to be great.
Just got to really get the energy.
We got a rush each other.
It's going to be cool.
Everyone's going to get freaked out.
You want to play smash tonight.
They're like best friends.
Um,
I don't know.
This whole thing is so transparent.
Who would you,
uh,
could you box the hood I box like.
Yeah,
because it's this whole thing with like
youtube or xbox boxing each other.
Who's your matcha box?
Um,
I would box.
what's this?
There's this toy channel with this
little kid.
It's really a toy channel.
Like little kid.
No,
there's really popular one.
Hold on a toy channel.
Youtube.
It's a kid.
I imagine most of them aren't,
right?
Maybe not actually.
I don't know.
Uh,
it's like Jay's toys or some shit.
Everybody knows what I'm talking about.
Anyway,
there's this toy channel.
They get like 300 million views a month.
It's just a little eight year old kid.
I would fucking beat the shit for all
the toys,
baby.
I can't beat up anybody and I fully
acknowledge that.
You know what I mean?
Sorry,
I am.
I wonder,
I wonder how I would do in a fight like
today,
like as a,
as an adult.
I don't know.
I get my ass beat.
Probably ever know.
Fight grown up.
Yeah.
But it's like you're a kid,
you're like major,
you know,
resilient.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Beat the a kid.
I mean,
most definitely.
I set it up.
I think I could take Jimmy Lee.
Ooh,
I pay for that.
What do you mean Roy?
Somebody just said Roy in our chat.
Roy.
I said,
Roy,
who's Roy?
Uh,
you.
Who is watching?
I think this is the toy channel.
Roy Roy.
It's not Roy.
She's helped [inaudible] was trying to
set up this match between me and the
angel.
He was doing work for me.
It was a chamfer standing up.
It's going to be so late.
Oh,
Ryan Ryan's toy review.
Ryan's toy review.
Brian,
I am coming for you and I'm fucking
pissed
it's going down.
Um,
what's an adult I could take?
Danny Devito.
Jimmy Lee,
for sure.
I feel like I could take peewee Herman,
but he's a little crazy.
He's old though.
He's Wiley.
Wiley.
I don't think there's not,
there's not many even feels bad.
But you actually gave me the clue.
I type Roy toys and it said Ryan.
So either you're on top of it tonight.
Oh God.
Who could I anyway,
let's focus enough about me.
Um,
right.
I'm going to come out.
I'm going to do this whole bit making
fun of the Japanese,
the suicide forest,
and,
and rushed me.
Notice when he,
then,
when they rushed each other,
by the way that he never actually throws
a punch.
They just like collide and then everyone
charges in to do like this iconic,
like,
no,
they went there.
No,
break it up.
Break it up.
Hold on.
There's this one where they rushed the
stage.
I have to find this.
Maybe we missed it already.
It's here.
It's,
what the fuck is he doing?
I look at,
this was the Nazi salute.
You see how uh,
you see.
Okay.
So I charged them but doesn't actually
throw up.
It's like,
what are you intending to do your bit?
You're going to be bald in two years.
Logan.
Imagine Logan Paul Bald and like a
Lamborghini,
like,
bawled,
like bawled,
like not even like bristles a baby.
I prefer the horseshoe.
Look.
Honestly,
the,
the old monastery left.
Imagine Logan Paul Balding sitting on a
wagon cooking meat.
Like a monk.
That's where it should be.
You still have that image in a robe with
a with,
with like,
you know,
controlling the horse.
That's Logan.
Paul.
It's a fucking monk.
Anyway,
it's just self address.
I'm sorry.
I think it's so funny.
I don't think there's anything genuine.
I don't think they.
You know,
and then here's the thing.
They're not.
They want to bring 20,000
people into an auditorium.
It's like,
Bro,
this is going to be guaranteed the least
entertaining boxing match ever.
These are two youtubers,
not trained professional fighters.
Nobody's going to get knocked out.
It's going to go the full distance of
the five because none of them have the
capacity or the physical ability to
knock each other out.
They're going to get tired after two
rounds.
There's gonna.
It's just gonna be a bunch of tired ass
dudes throwing punches at each other.
It's going to end in a judge decision
and honestly you could go either way
because who fucking cares at that point
because you paid hundreds of dollars to
watch essentially to untrained fighters,
a throat wet noodles at each other,
which is basically all they're going to
be throwing after two rounds.
You think?
I mean this is like you pointed out,
this is obviously stage.
Do you think the fight is going to be
genuine in any way or is it like
wrestling and it's pretty good?
I think it'll be real because they both
want to win.
Sure.
But I don't think either of them can
knock each other out.
I don't.
I really genuinely don't know they're
doing this twice.
There's like another fight date in
January.
Yeah,
one of the first in the UK,
but then they're doing a us one.
We should go.
No,
I hear you.
But I also think a lot of people are
going to do that.
I mean maybe it could be.
You know,
it would be fun.
I've been wanting to plan a man on the
street segment.
Maybe I've been wanting to do something
with Joey Salads for some reason where I
sent him like man on the street,
so or maybe not even joe sells,
but maybe someone we actually respect to
go create a segment,
you know,
and play it on the podcast.
I mean,
Shit Dude,
I think that's a great idea.
And Ian,
you down,
you're down to go to the UK to go watch
a kids eye versus logan?
No,
he's in La.
I thought.
No,
I think.
Well the first one is in the UK.
Okay.
Oh that makes sense.
I was wondering whether they're going to
do it in the UK because l okay.
That,
that's interesting.
August 25th in the UK.
Second fight is scheduled for February
20,
19 in an undecided venue in the US.
Probably La Logan.
Paul is basically,
he's fallen from grace.
I don't think he's selling maverick.
Merge his vlogs on getting that many
views.
Did it about a $7,000,000
house.
You know,
the property tax on $7,000,000
house.
I mean you're looking at well to one
percent,
so it's.
Is that $70,000
a year every year forever.
I'm sure that youtube money we'll keep
rolling in,
right?
Yeah,
probably but like to an extent,
but I mean when he bought that house he
was at his peak.
Yeah.
And now we'll look what he's doing now.
I'm sure he's going to get paid
handsomely,
but the thing is,
I haven't watched other people's
reaction to this,
but hopefully they also don't get taken
in with like there's a lot of details of
like,
look,
when a look when Ksi told comedy shorts
Gamer to chill,
look at all these details.
Oh look what that means.
It's all a bunch of fucking bullshit.
Look in the crowd by the way.
All these kids.
All right.
I've talked enough about this.
Honestly,
I'm boring myself,
but there was one funny detail.
It's like,
wow,
they're,
they're selling out this arena.
It's the biggest sporting arena and
Europe apparently I read and I was like,
wow,
I wonder.
I wonder how they're the ticket sales
are because the fight is coming up
pretty soon.
So I'm go to the seating plan
and I'm like,
Holy Shit.
There's a lot of fucking seats.
Do I scroll down here?
So these were never opened.
These are closed and these are,
there's a lot of seats available.
You know like these,
these are quite possibly we're never
opened.
I just looked it up with 21,000.
Is the capacity of that arena.
It doesn't even look like they're at
half of that.
Yeah,
I don't think so.
I mean it's not,
it isn't that far off next month I
guess.
Yeah.
I mean you don't,
you don't.
The ticket sales don't go up.
Right,
right.
What I'm going to be looking at when I
watched that is I want to see the seats.
I want to see.
Well what usually what they do is
they'll like,
they'll try to fill the,
pack it all in where the camera's
consumed for sure.
Like all these like ring side seem
filled.
But what is that like 2000 at most?
Probably not even that.
Maybe a thousand.
That's crazy.
Ringside seats man.
It was funny but apparently yeah.
Apparently it's like $600 for a ringside
seat.
Not Worth it.
Sorry.
And that's not my budget.
Let me see,
ticket prices and who fucking cares.
I mean,
seriously,
who gives a shit?
So I don't know.
That's what I have to say about that.
There you go.
There it is.
Just like forrest gump and that's what I
have to say about that.
But nobody's clapping for me.
I got you.
Thank you.
At least one person on youtube is
genuine.
Thank you.
I deserve that.
Um,
last week we spoke about Metamucil,
which is what,
Chris,
this is what everyone has been waiting
for.
Really?
Oh yeah.
It's 30,000
people watching right now.
Everybody's saying for this.
It was waiting for this.
So it was recommended to me.
Um,
and I bought it.
It's kind of expensive by the way.
It was like 25 bucks for like 300
capsules.
And when you get the bottle it says take
five a day.
It's like these huge pills.
Oh,
Jesus.
Okay.
Five a day.
Yeah.
It was like damn.
But then I was like,
I'm not taking five.
They'll not like a horse.
It's like a huge pill of like wheat,
like,
yeah,
of course it's going to clean my bowels.
Why don't I just eat a banana at that
point?
Well,
I'd rather you'd have banana.
Anyway.
I take two pills and this is a night
where I'm going out to a party and for
dinner I have pizza and I have alcohol
now for any mortal man,
any one of us,
this would result an absolute
catastrophe.
Total.
A wasteland.
Okay.
Of the anus and asshole area.
Frankly.
Sometimes I should.
So disgusting.
When I have diarrhea,
it sprays on my thighs and I'm not going
to lie.
Sometimes it happens sometimes.
I mean sometimes you blast and it really
hits the side of the road.
The deflection,
ice.
I just thought you were like a shotgun
blast and it was just,
you know,
it's a buck shot at sometimes you.
Sometimes I'll be sad when I have a meal
like this.
You're wiping as I do this way.
Don't fucking hate on me.
There were met by the way.
Ian fessed up.
He's a front.
He's a at the front.
When,
when you guys were arguing about it on
air.
Ian and I were arguing about it back
here.
You know,
I got to say too,
I was curious that night I went home and
I tried it your way and I gotta say it's
inferior.
It's not a fear.
You are not used to it.
If I tried it your way wouldn't respond.
I have years,
decades of experience wiping it's muscle
memory.
Dan.
Yet will you.
What do you expect to go home and just
live?
Live one evening in my asshole.
And you think that's,
that's Dan.
You,
you don't know what you're talking about
is I should give it another shot and
fret.
And frankly I'm,
I'm in the middle of something,
right?
I'm talking about my shotgun.
Diarrhea.
So the verdict is still out.
So
you ever have a shit so nasty like you
wipe and then you're like,
I better check my thighs and cheeks just
to be safe.
Sometimes.
That's reality for me.
And this was one of those meals.
So I take these pills.
I took two of them,
not five before I go out because when
I'm have fucking human garbage disposal,
what am I taking five?
It's a little ridiculous and I have to
say it the next morning I had the shit
just slid out of my asshole with
elegance and grace and a supple,
a supple glide almost as if to say,
hey,
you know,
it's going to be okay.
Wow.
And uh,
and I went to wipe and I wasn't a
oneweb.
There was,
it was some,
but not a lot.
I would say it was a three way.
I don't necessarily have the courage not
to end with a wetland.
I ended wet cause I mean,
that's just part of who I am,
but I was,
I was shocked.
I was absolutely shocked by that first
day result I was blown away.
But since then I've been taking it every
day with my meal and I have to say I'm
not,
I'm still not totally sold because
it's,
it's a weird thing,
like it's like greases your shit.
It like slides out of your asshole,
like somebody sprayed,
you know,
spent like a pam on your anus is like,
it's just,
it's,
it's not,
it's like a,
it's like your anus.
It's like your intestines is made of
Teflon and it's kind of a strange
phenomenon in front being honest.
It just slides right out.
Wow.
I wasn't curious before,
but now that you've explained the CRESCO
ass.
No,
I swear to God if you.
If you try these,
you will experience a difference in and
bowel movements so it on the bottle it
says it can take up to seven days for
your body to adjust to actually getting
fiber for the first time in its life.
So I mean I'm enjoying,
I'm enjoying it so far and I'm going to.
I'm going to keep reporting back but
it's real interesting.
But it's a mixed bag.
You're saying like if it's not off a
little bit after that initial.
No,
no,
it's been pretty good.
It's good.
It hasn't gotten better because I was
like wow,
I had pizza and alcohol and my shit was
this clean,
but I've had good days and my shit
wasn't better than that.
You know what I mean?
Which was what I was expecting.
So I'll,
I'll,
I'll keep.
I'm going to keep taking it.
Like,
I mean I enjoy it.
I enjoy having my,
my asshole basically,
you know,
like a,
like a slip and slide essentially,
you know,
the slip inside.
But do you know the ones where you hit
the end and then you splash up and
splash out lamp?
It's got like an alligator's head.
It's like that.
So I like it.
Alright,
I'm going to have to give it a shot.
I'm going to sell so much of these
fucking metamucil is man.
Where's my sponsor?
This up bear or whoever it is.
Um,
because I'm away.
I wrote a song for Ila.
Me and my friends wrote a song for you
since she's gone and I'm the wizard of
loneliness as I've previously coined.
Um,
we'll get to that at the end.
But let's see,
I've got the WOMP womp clip.
Let me,
let me play this real fast because I
love it so much.
I mean,
look,
I read today I don't,
I don't like to talk about politics that
much these days,
but oh my God,
this is,
this is special folks.
This is this a special.
Let me look.
I read today about a 10 year old girl
with Down's syndrome who was taken from
her mother and put in a cage.
I wrote about a try.
I read of a of a girl with down syndrome
being put in a cage.
WOMP womp.
She's so fucking priceless.
Crazy.
It's just so bright girl with Down's
syndrome who was taken from her mother
and put in a cage.
I wrote about a.
Did you say down syndrome?
That's what he said.
Politics is such a shit show.
I love it.
It's such a circus.
This is basically comparable to Ksi
verse Logan Paul Right now,
except with like little little kids.
Did you just say,
womp womp,
bet your fucking ass.
I won't bump to.
And that little girl with down syndrome.
So unabashed about just taken from her
mother.
Didn't put in a cage.
I wrote about a.
God bless him.
Dan had a funny note about this.
He said,
this is Corey Lewandowski.
Ruined Down Lewandowski are,
or as you might say,
Luhan against down skews.
Might not hurt.
That's true.
That's too good.
Well done.
Corey Lewin against down skis.
It was trump's 2016 campaign manager
until he was replaced by Paul Manafort
who is currently in jail.
So this is a,
this is a winning winners.
And this is a office you want to hold.
Lewin Lewin against.
Downscale.
Refused to apologize for the remark when
asked about it on Fox News.
WOMP womp.
I just,
it cracked me up.
I was just like,
whoa.
He womp womp to fucking down syndrome,
baby.
Crazy.
Really?
This,
I've got this.
I've got this Jimmy Lee clip.
Um,
I guess I might throw it on.
And then I want to play this song for
all you guys.
I got a song please.
I want you to watch it.
So don't go away.
This is very important to me and to my
friends who wrote it with me and to Isla
and to shredder who almost died today.
Maybe I should just play it.
Well,
this is going to take us out,
right?
Do we need to say goodbye now?
I'm gonna.
Watch Jimmy Lee.
Oh Shit.
Hang on.
There's really not much to say about our
old friend Jimmy Lee is up to some
antics that I find pretty funny.
Um,
what are the numbers that,
how are we doing?
Doing good.
20,
29,
29 point five.
Nice.
Welcome everybody.
Thanks for tuning in.
God bless you.
Appreciate you so very much.
A Jimmy Lee,
the Jersey outlaw.
He's still at it.
He's dangerously funny.
Do you remember Jimmy Lee?
Probably.
He's like this incredibly racist,
abrasive unfunny.
Just really a character and the worst
way possible.
We had him as a guest.
It was one of the worst episodes we had
as mad as a guest and after our first
break,
me Dan and Isla were huddled in the
corner.
He was outside and we're like,
did we can't,
this can't go on.
We have to end this.
So we actually gave them the,
the,
the cartoon came off the stage.
It's frankly,
it's our fault.
I think that we should have anticipated
that this would have.
It was a formative experience for us.
We didn't really know what we were doing
at the time,
but it's fine.
It was,
it was early days,
but anyway,
he started view body.
He doesn't actually,
I'm having an engaged audience,
but this video has one point,
2 million views,
94 comments and 900 likes.
So he started view bonding,
which I find pretty,
pretty terrific.
Once sick of the comments,
Jimmy,
you're my father.
I don't think a youtube video has ever
made me laugh so hard.
Oh,
cheers to you about literally couldn't
finish this one,
made it halfway and stopped too cringey.
Well,
anyway,
let's,
let's give you a taste of this viral hit
God,
Jesus Christ.
And you mixed your fucking audio right?
So the video starts while you watch for
yourself.
The video starts with five seconds for
the video.
Begins with them having crowds of people
pretending to know who he is,
which is a phenomenon I've noticed,
you know,
spring in his videos.
It's a part of his plan to view,
but I guess is that he's,
he's building this great story about
himself.
He's got security guards,
perfect.
Say Dangerous,
really funny or comedy reality show on
television.
It hits three,
2018,
by the way,
every year he's like,
my new hit series is hitting spring
2017,
spring 2016.
It's like,
man,
we are all waiting for that hit big
breath.
Can't wait.
Yeah,
that's a lot of enthusiasm and he got it
from them.
What are you,
the president?
You've got like secret service with air
pieces and shit and I can't watch this.
I really.
It's so painful.
I just thought it was funny.
I thought it was like Damn Jimmy.
Still trying to.
In a way,
you've got to give it up till till Jimmy
like,
you know what?
Let's watch a clip.
Let me.
Don't cut them off.
Let's do it.
Let's see.
Some of his comedy or weekly.
How often were you brought up?
How are you,
but don't recognize you.
Nikki's cowboy fall.
You frustrated.
You're wanting to talk to Jimmy.
Oh,
just what happens when your parents beat
you up as a kid.
He's like,
am I right to the guy?
So let me ask you something.
Urban Cowboy.
Brett,
zoom in.
Zoom in.
No,
no,
no.
Let's get this first date or second date
where your quickie or a long time ago.
Wow.
Tell me how you did it.
I'm going to ask when you were younger,
was working in equipment work better?
Like what are you doing on a daily or
weekly?
How often were you?
Um,
were you a quick,
quick or are good?
Good.
Take your time and draw it
stuff folks.
Obviously funny and really we were
putting our audience in danger.
Showing them.
We've seen,
we've seen enough.
If you guys want to go through,
I want to say cringe.
Afterlife.
Jim Lee shot.
He's a friend of the show.
He's a great guy.
I hope to hear from him soon.
I'd love to get him involved in some
kind of segment,
you know,
because some dude at Jimmy is a true,
like a,
like a goof spoofer.
I'm trying to think of like a walk back.
Did we ever settle on a whack back man?
For us there was the gas pack.
I was personally the gift bag.
I liked gathpath.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's an original gath packer.
Alright.
Well,
I got to say,
I hope the show was okay.
I felt like I was bombing in here,
especially the first half.
You're doing fine because you start
sweating.
There's nobody in here too.
I'm like,
oh my God.
Stuff without either.
It's tough without Isla.
And that's why me and my friends,
we started playing music.
What called the jokes last time either
was gone.
We started working on this song called
Goldmine and now the eel is gone.
We finalize this.
It's a beautiful tribute to isla client.
Um,
my better half.
I miss her and I love her.
So with that being said,
this is the world debut of the jokes and
guys,
I will see you next Friday at the
regular time with Bob Berman.
I'm so excited for that and I hope you
enjoyed the show.
Would that being said,
play us off
where I can go out and do what you use
in a bowl and I'm so and a to stones
throw because I just bought,
you know,
it's just me listening to ed goes with a
sunset.
It's all fools gold man.
Yeah man,
I'm so,
so cold though.
About a stone's throw,
but I just want,
you know,
I tapped the vein.
The vault is full.
I had the midas touch,
but it's all fools gold with that and
I'm to.